turkey has made good on threats to allow
migrants to move closer to the European
Union Ankara says 18,000 people have
crossed the border since Friday there's
been arrivals by land and by sea along
borders with Greece and Bulgaria but
both countries have boosted security at
their borders with Turkey and thousands
of migrants are now stuck in no-man's
land between the two sides Turkish
officials announced they would no longer
stop migrants from crossing into Europe
after dozens of Turkish troops were
killed in a Syrian government we have
disabled persons there and they fired
tear gas on them we have been joined
right now here I don't know why they are
doing this we don't have peace in our
own country we don't have future in our
own country that's why
we came here to make up a life make a
new life
they don't DW correspondent Julia Hahn
is in a journal right at the Turkish
Greek border Julia tell us what it's
like on the border today well right now
the situation is a very tense here
because a Greek border police over there
are firing warning shots with that tear
gas or pepper spray it's not entirely
clear what it is so people there are
hundreds of people here right now they
keep running towards where we are they
have tears and eyes there are coughing
some people actually look like they're
about to faint
there are medics around here and a-teams
but this looks very serious for the
people who've been closed I'm sure you
can hear the noise there of shooting
that's over there let me explain you
where we are we are here right at the
Turkish border with Greece and there is
this border zone right behind me about
200 to 300 meters long and this is where
people are this is some kind of no-man's
land between Turkey and Greece and you
can see there is a fence and people are
trying to actually move here I'm sorry
this is for the people here a really
tense situation so the Turkish
authorities have let them in but on the
other side the Greek side the border is
closed
people can't across and the Greek border
police control is actually acting very
tough firing these shots to try and keep
people away
Julia by the looks of it this story is
literally developing at your feet what
can you tell me about the conditions for
the people there as they as they gather
at the border there
well it's been a very rough night for
people here at this border crossing many
have spent the night here in freezing
temperatures it's still bitterly cold
the air in general is filled with smoke
because people have been making fires
they're burning woods and whatever they
can find there are many families here
with small children so you can imagine
how rough this is for them and we see
new people keep coming I've just talked
to one family who's originally from Iran
who was living here in Turkey and they
told me they heard the border was open
so they came they took a leap of faith
they want to cross into Greece and then
potentially move on to a Scandinavian
country that's their dream but the
reality here as you can see looks quite
different quite desperate and as you can
see it's very crowded hundreds of people
here but as I said the border is closed
the Greek border police won't let
anybody in here at the moment no sign as
far as I can see from these images that
that will change anytime soon is there
any sign of Turkey or the EU changing
their stance on the border situation
there Yulia well generally what the
Turkish authorities are doing here by
turning a blind eyes is seen as some
kind of an attempt to pressure NATO
allies and the European Union over the
situation in Syria in Italy where the
Turkish army is involved in direct
clashes with the forces of the Syrian
regime and deadly clashes they want
international help they want the EU to
step in so this is widely seen as some
kind of a measure a temporary measure to
alert attention to this situation to
pressure the EU into acting as I said
many assume this is some kind of a
temporary thing but the refugees the
migrants here they have been wasting no
time as soon as
they heard the border would be open they
just came here and now they are
determined to wait until this border
will be opened but as you can imagine
the frustration is also running high
here because people are seeing there is
no way they can pass over to Greece at
the moment DWS Yulia Hahn live in
Arizona at the Turkish Greek border
thank you so much for that report